okay
[Applause]
that right there could have been pretty
awkward all right tonight can be the
exhale I already feel the outside a sigh
of relief for Austin Butler and Vanessa
Hudgins at the 2023 Academy Awards who
successfully avoided each other on
Hollywood's biggest night the two dated
for almost a decade before they went
their separate ways in 2020. we'll
always have each other's back so it's
nice but during Sunday's Oscars Vanessa
had her back to Austin where the exes
had a near run in
yeah that's the actor exiting the Vanity
Fair Oscars party while chatting with
Sharon Stone did you enjoy the show
tonight Sharon oh my God it was
wonderful but it was outside the bash
where Austin and Vanessa nearly missed
each other just a couple feet of
distance between them
[Applause]
the looks of it seems like Austin didn't
even notice his former GF was nearby as
for Vanessa that's a different story the
fans and Paparazzi didn't hold back
oh my God
while Austin left the party chatting
with Sharon
you love Kaya Gerber was his date for
The star-studded Bash where Vanessa did
run into friends like Emma Roberts
everyone's Journey to the Oscars is
different yeah Vanessa actually spent
the night working hosting ABC's
countdown to the Oscars pre-show Where
She interviewed stars and nominees alike
on full display her new engagement ring
we're like the same person MLB Pro Cole
Tucker popped the question on New Year's
Eve after two years of dating
Elvis or I mean sorry Austin thankfully
Vanessa didn't have to chat with her
oscar-nominated ex that task went to
co-host Ashley Graham we learned a lot
of talk about the blue Elvis what are
you doing with all these Awards and
where are you putting them you find
places and the Oscar goes to Brendan
fazer
Austin left the ceremony empty-handed
but his performance as the king of rock
and roll nabbed him plenty of trophies
the whole beginning process of this was
was me kind of going do I believe I can
do it there was an Elvis Christmas song
on the radio and I was with a friend of
mine and I was singing along and my
friend kind of looked over at me and
goes
yeah that friend was Vanessa he was
sitting at the piano he's a musician and
he's playing and he's singing and I'm
like I I don't know how but we need to
figure out how you can play Elvis she
said I'm serious you got to figure out
how you can get the rights to a script
and like write something like I don't
know
how like what we do but like we need to
play him it is your calling is this his
friend I need to yeah yeah yeah I'll
give you the number yep she was there
from the start making Vanessa and
Austin's near running a Bittersweet full
circle moment for the X's
[Music]